So we've been talking about simplifying terms in the context of simplifying
expressions for a while, and our whole goal with doing all this is to make our
expressions look prettier. To make them easier to read, but still let us know
what kind of math we're talking about. So something we're doing a lot of is
taking shortcuts. In fact, most of the time that you do this, you probably don't
even realize that, that's what's happening. let's say for example that we have
something like 2 plus 2, plus 2, plus 2, plus 2. So we have five 2's added
together. Now normally if we wanted to express this quantity, we wouldn't write
it this way. We wouldn't write all the 2's added together. Instead we would say,
okay, how many 2's do you want to add? 5, well that's just the same as 5 times
2, since we've added 2 to itself 5 times. So as it turns out, multiplication is
actually just a major short cut to repeated addition. In the same way, we can
use exponents to indicate repeated multiplication of the same number. So let's
say that instead of having 2 plus 2 plus 2 plus 2 plus 2 We have 5 2's
multiplied together. In this case, we can use another kind of shortcut. We can
rewrite this using an exponent, Just like we talked about in the last quiz. You
may have already had a lot practice with exponents in previous courses, but just
in case you've forgotten exactly how they work, we're going to talk about that
right now. So let's write this, these 5 2's multiplied together, using
exponential notation. So we're going to start by identifying the number that we
want to multiply it by itself. So in that case this is 2. So let's write that
down, and then we count how many of these 2's are multiplied together. So we
know that we have 5, And we take that number 5, The number of 2s we're
multiplying. And we write that as a superscript of 2. So superscript is just a
small number written to the upper right-hand corner of this other number. And we
call 2, the number that we're multiplying over and over again, the b ase number,
and we this little 5, its exponent. Now, since you're going to be entering most
of your answers on a computer for this class, or probably all of your answers,
actually, considering this is an online course, you're going to have to type in
answers with exponents in a special way. So what you do is you type in the base
number, normally, so you would type in a 2. But then, in order to type the
number that's in the exponent, or in order to indicate that this 5 is in this
exponent slot, we need to write a caret before the 5. So these are the three
keys that you will type, in order, to enter this exact answer on a computer.
It's like this little arrow here is pointing up to indicate that this number
that follows it is going to be in that higher elevated exponent position, as you
can see down here. Now if you have more than just a number in the exponent, then
you put parentheses around the entire expression that you want to have
positioned in that exponent spot.